[Music]
hi my name is garrett parish and i'm a
senior at mit studying mechanical
engineering and entertainment technology
i'm also a musician designer and
engineer and i spend my time combining
all three of those disciplines
using technology
um i usually wake up at around eight
o'clock in the morning
um start you know getting ready for the
day have my trader joe's
raspberry oatmeal every single day um
then
i usually leave the house about 9 30 or
so i usually don't have class in the
morning so i
either work on some of my music or my
homework or
some of the other projects i'm working
on grab some lunch in kendall square or
around campus
go to class usually in the afternoon for
a couple hours
and then at night i usually have
rehearsal or some other
you know meeting with some of the
various activities i do and then
come back to the house for dinner hang
out with friends
you know do my work and then eventually
get back to sleep
[Music]
you you mentioned combining music
technology engineering sort of broadly
speaking what does that look like what
does that mean
so i try very very consciously not to
pigeonhole myself into one discipline i
think it's really important for
everybody to do that ever since i was
really young
i've always done both music and
engineering and that was you know my
path throughout high school and into
college
um because i'm equally passionate about
both and you know both are
absolutely critical to who i am as a
human being um
and i think that when you can combine
them
effectively you can achieve far more
than you could with just one of them
so it was really mit that showed me that
that was possible
and that i could not have to keep those
two parts of my life separate and just
do them both at the same time
so what is a what is your living
situation look like
so i live in a co-ed literary fraternity
of about 60 students
called the number six club we live on
campus even though it's privately owned
and we eat together socialize together
work together
hang out together go out together and
it's a really really
wonderful community of people one of the
most interesting parts about it is that
there's a high constituent of
international students so i'm actually
one of only
about three or four americans that live
in the house and it's really interesting
to
be able to be exposed to different
cultures from all around the world
greece sweden germany colombia venezuela
all over the place
i mean it's really cool because
everyone's kind of an outsider so it
really brings everybody together and
like a true
family um of students walk me around uh
uh this room then sure so a lot going on
here
this is i i call this my castle um
because i really like castles and
because i'm obsessed with disney
obviously dramatically yeah
um so first most and most important part
is the ceiling
um this is replica of the night sky my
uh the girl who had the room before me
actually painted it but then i
installed all the lights and one of the
great things about number six is that
they allow you to renovate your room and
do what you want with it
within reason and even reimburse you for
parts of it
so i put in the floor i painted added
the lights
and really you know made it my own space
and a place that i
feel comfortable coming home to so it's
not just a dorm room
[Music]
so over here i kind of have my music
space so
um this is my electronic drum set which
allows me to play drums at any time of
the night and not bother anybody
so this is my desk where i do most of my
work right now i'm working on an
arrangement for the
jazz ensemble that i play in here it's
debuting in about a month
and behind my desk i have a lot of the
drawings i do and i've always been
fascinated with the disney characters
and i really was interested in getting
to know more about visual art and
actually
took a drawing class here at mit which
really opened my eyes about
um not being afraid to just you know
dive into something so
um these are a lot of my first sketches
and color drawings of the diff
the characters um and it's been a really
good experience
so uh so what's this building here so
this is kresge auditorium
it's the main concert and event space on
campus
and this is where most of the music uh
concerts and recitals and events happen
okay
and so so what what does the music scene
look like at mit
so there's a common misconception about
mit that it's
all engineering and just science matters
and numbers all the time
but that's totally not true there's a
very vibrant art scene there's very
vibrant music scene i've mainly been
involved in the music scene here
um there's uh jazz ensemble there's
choruses there's
orchestras symphony orchestras win
ensemble
african drumming groups pretty much
anything that you could imagine and the
administration is really really
supportive of students
that are want to get involved in the
arts because you know everybody here is
studying some form of engineering or
science so
um the art and music groups you know
have a really really nice camaraderie
because everyone is doing it
purely because they're passionate
[Music]
so what uh what do you major in at mit
so i'm majoring in mechanical
engineering um
with a flexible concentration that
allows me to focus on something else and
that concentration is entertainment
technology
is that a flexible concentration that
you built or was that sort of
pre-existing
so there are some pre-existing ones like
energy transportation
uh robotics but i decided to create my
own
uh flexible custom concentration in
entertainment and what what did that
process look like building that
concentration so
it's surprisingly simple mit does
does have a lot of support for you know
students kind of making their own
versions of their majors and course two
mechanical engineering
has an option that you can submit a
proposal with a list of classes
um that are relevant and you you know
write some essays about why it's
important to you why
each class contributes to this and you
submit the
proposal and you talk to your advisor
and hopefully you can get approved
great great what do you think makes the
mit engineering departments
different or special as compared to
other schools from your college
so i think there's been a big push in
the past couple decades you know to
increase stem education and engineering
uh the thing about mit is that they've
been
doing it long long before is ever cool
to be
building things not the concern right
and the
professors here you know they're the
people that invented the internet
invented all these technologies that um
you know are so ubiquitous to us now
so just the amount of community
knowledge
is just unfathomable and you get to
learn from these
true leaders in every single
technological field
so you never have to worry that you know
you're learning the right thing
or you're thinking about things
correctly because
they're just so good at what they do
they just like okay this is what you got
to know
you're gonna be in this situation you're
gonna have to think about it this way so
you need to learn this and that and et
cetera so it's just
really really helpful to be in class and
to just
be able to just completely pay attention
and be like okay i know what i'm
supposed to know
and then just go do it yeah yeah and i
think there's a huge focus at mit
on practical learning and i think that's
something that a lot of other schools
and a lot of other communities are
really trying to ramp up
but the idea of you know learning
through doing and mit's motto is mind in
hand
so you both you know study theory but
then you have really intense lab classes
and
mit really actually gives you tangible
skills that
you can use to build things to make
things to design things
um that you know are hard to get
sometimes
do you have a good example of a of a
class where
you had a cool learning by doing
experience so
uh the mechanical engineering capstone
class is called 2009 and it's the
product engineering process
and it's a class truly like no other so
there's eight teams of students
each gets a budget of about seven
thousand dollars and over the course of
this
uh semester the 20 people on your team
have to
come up with a product design it build
it
and then pitch it by the end of the
semester and you do every every stage
every single stage you're basically like
a little startup and
you go from you know a blank sheet of
paper to being on stage and kresge
you know pitching your product to the
world and you know you have
space and lab to do it you have
professors you have technical
instructors to help you communication
instructors
but just the experience of being given
the opportunity to be in a leadership
position um in at such a young age and
when you're
just coming off of all of your rigorous
technical education
like you actually learn a lot of the
other problems that go into making
anything because it's not just the
equations and everything it's you know
how do you deal with people how do you
design for a human being how do you you
know design something to be manufactured
and having the opportunity in a safe you
know constructive learning environment
to do that when the stakes aren't huge
is incredibly valuable
[Music]
before we let you go and do all the work
you got to do do you have
any parting wisdom for high school
students any like mantras
yeah um so i think uh something i live
by
is the idea that it's okay to be in the
middle and to not
you know live in an extreme world and
not pigeonhole yourself in one
discipline
and it's okay to you know both like art
and engineering or
both want to do music and do something
completely different
and it's okay to have different
interests and it's really important you
know to show that
um you know if you're applying to
college or just in life general
generally um because those parts you
know
of you that you know you don't always
service through your school major or
through your research
there's still parts of you so they need
to be celebrated
[Music]
so if you like this video and want to
learn more about colleges
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
all right so if you like this video and
you want to learn more
that's okay i got my finger on the
button